大家好
欢迎回到视野环球财经
我是Ryno
现在是美东时间
26年9月4号
周五晚上的8点20分
今天的四大指数是纳指读涨
其中紫板块方面
费城半导体表现非常的出色
30只成分股是全部上涨
而且大涨的股票很多
反观今天的标普成分股
有324只下跌
178只上涨
标普的11个板块
有八个下跌
今天这个市场
大家是不是觉得似曾相识
又回到了之前
费半吸血市场的行情
那么这个到底是费半的一日游呢
还是它的底部已成
到底有没有持续性
咱们后面来分析这个问题
在讲解这些之前
咱们先来看一下今天的飞浓
大家别着急
等会我们把像费半
还有甲骨一下周的财报波动
包括AMD还有特斯拉
都和大家跟一下
首先我们看一下
今天的8月非农报告
新增的旧月的
这个非农的人数
是16.2万个
高于预期的5.6万
还有之前修正的2.1万
那么几乎这个值
是预期的差不多是三倍
比这个普遍预期
是高出了四个标准差
另外今天的失业率
是维持在4.1%不变符合预期
劳动参与率从61.4升到了61.6
那么其中私营部门的新增就业岗位
是12.7万个
预期是4.5万个
大幅超预期
制造业新增就业岗位1.6万个
预期是5000个
政府部门新增就业岗位是3.5万个
那么之前是负5万个
工资环比增长0.3%
之前是0.2%
年化增长率是从3.2%
略微降到了3.1%
但是仍旧高于3%的普遍预期
今天的非农报告非常的强劲
是提振了整个的市场鹰派情绪
目前9月加息的概率
是从昨天的差不多50%
上升到58%左右
下个星期还有一份非常重要的
美国的通胀报告会成为一个关键的催化剂
如果这个通胀数据大幅高于预期
那么预计这个加息概率还会进一步提升
那么反之呢
预计美联储在9月
维持利率不变的可能性还是比较高的
好
这个就是今天的非农
接下来呢
咱们就讲一讲大家可能比较关心的半导体啊
今天整个的市场的活跃程度最高的
就是费城半导体
当然这个就得感谢一下这个OpenAI了
为什么要感谢他们呢
因为他们推出了一个新的这个模型
这个Astro
它是重振了人工智能的交易市场
目前看到有的数据说呢
说这个模型啊
在某些方面已经超越了
这个Azoropec的这个模型
并且呢
在基准测试的AGI中分数很高
人工智能的通用性
甚至超越了人类的能力
所以啊
OpenAI相关的半导体和数据中心
表现是非常优异
你比如说你看一下软银对吧
软银的股价是飙升了超过10%
还有呢
甲骨纹是上涨了差不多3%
好
那么这个为什么会有一个这么大的推动呢
像打了一个兴奋机一样
其实它这里边呢
有一个潜在的逻辑啊
就是一个市场在炒什么东西
那么这个新模型推动半导体大涨的叙事逻辑
大概是这样啊
就是当这个模型呢
有更新的更好的更加智能的推出来的时候
企业不会仅仅以更低的价格
使用相同数量的人工智能
他们会找到新的理由来使用人工智能
就是以前的东西可能一般般
没有达到预期
或者说工作上我就用这个就够了
但现在有更新更好的更厉害的
它可能会让它的需求
去整个的格局发生一些变化
另外从同行来讲
它会迫使其他的模型奋起直追
大家要竞争嘛
所以整个有新的模型带动
更厉害的模型带动
那么同行竞争也会积极的去投入
所以整个的逻辑链条就是
防止了支出周期的停滞不前
一句话就是竞争带来的繁荣
所以不管你信不信这个叙事
但今天费半的价格确实是大幅上涨
资金是用脚投票
选择是继续参与这个游戏
特别是今天我们看到横盘很久的
像什么一些存储股票
美光啊
S&DK啊
都是大幅上涨那么费瓣的这个热情它到底是一日游还是底部已经成了呢给大家看一下我首先说答案
答案是截止到今天为止
买盘强劲这件事情是事实
信心也开始恢复
但是截止到今天还不能够确定
就是底部
如果要成为底部趋势转好
它是有条件的
今天我给大家画了一些东西
也新标注了一些内容
大家可以看一下
这一波最低
在最近昨天的时候
最低是下探到489
486这个地方勉强守住
并没有开盘或者说收盘价跌破这个位置
好
那么在这个地方
获得了一剂强心针
注入了兴奋剂
今天是一个放量上涨
那么现在的看点在哪里
从这一轮下跌下来
其实有一条下降趋势线的压制
大概的位置
大概是在530到532
就从今天来讲
往后
如果我们明天
今天不是收盘了吗
明天下个星期的往后
差不多就是这个地方
你也可以拿另外一个指标
就是100日的移动平均线
它这个100日的移动平均线
其实还要向上缓慢的走
那么这个地方
这条下降趋势线
从技术性的看法来讲
一旦它完成了突破
其实从结构上
这一波下行横盘
它就得到了极大的改善
趋势就可以慢慢的往上走
底部会逐步的抬高
所以这个地方我们还需要得到一个更加明确的确认
就是它到底是遇到了下行趋势线
继续被压回来
还是能一口气向上突破
然后这个动能进一步增强
特别是当买盘增加之后
信心增强之后
资金重新注入之后
那就有更大的机会向上去突破上方的这个高点
就是这个550到577
不好意思刚才把它给删掉了
550到577
之前写的是580
这个给大家调整了一下
550到577突破之后
就能够看到新高
好吧
所以分两步走
第一步寻求530
大概到532左右的一个突破
当然这个突破
如果拖的比较晚
横盘横了几天
位置可能会下降
可能还会下降一些
可能就到什么更低的位置了
我们这里讲述的是
下个星期
大概一两天两三天之内
它会突破的情况
大概在这个地方
如果拖上一个星期
那这个位置会更低
大概就跑到了520几块
好
突破之后
第二笔就看550到557的反转
真正的大结构反转的发生
反转之后
那就不用想了
继续非诚半导体的叙事就往上走
相关的成分股
大家该好的也都会好起来
因为今天很多成分股
其实都在放量
这是一个非常好的迹象
对于沉寂了许久的非诚来讲
这是一个机会
特别是这个新的叙事带来的新机会
那么反之呢
还有一个观察点就是
一旦费城半导体真的启示
市场会不会像之前一样
其他的被严重的吸血
资金又重新一股脑的只压住费半
当然现在的情况有一些不同啊
比如软件其实已经是突破了
还有四大科技
其实呢
他们往上走的也还可以
尽管最近像亚马逊和谷歌都是在走一个回撤
所以这个翘翘板会不会形成
还是说大家齐头并进
这个看点是后面我们去研究的
今天我们看不到太多
这个需要几天的走势来进行判断
一天的涨跌
没有办法去看一个大趋势
好
那么首先这个是废办
还有就是关于甲骨文
大家会看到
其实今天整体的软件表现都不好
但是甲骨文今天不错
为什么
刚才我讲过原因
因为甲骨文
它是OpenAI重要的生态的盟友
OpenAI表现的越好
越成功
越领先
那么对甲骨文来讲
它的压力就越小
它未来收到钱
收到合同
承诺这个钱的收回来的可能性就越大
市场不是担心它收不回来吗
对吧
好
它是下个星期发布财报
我给大家首先把财报的波动情况讲一下
它的财报是160块上下19美元以内波动
是68%的大概率
那么19块钱的波动和160的股价来讲
那都超过了123%了
12点多了对吧
13多了差不多
那是一个非常大的波动
160往上加上19块
差不多能跑到接近180块
160往下减掉19 20块差不多又掉到140块也就是在这两个区间现在画出来的上下的这两个区间之内
好
那么甲骨文的本身自己靠自己去走
他没有open eye的利好推动比较的难
我们之前也讲过他的压力是比较大的
特别是上方
这一轮反弹
如果真的能反弹到187到203
真的已经是非常非常的厉害了
非常非常的好了
因为203再过之后
那它往上的空间就会逐渐的打开了
所以这一波
看它能不能够
利用这一次的财报
包括OpenAI的利好消息
能够往上多推一点
也帮很多之前还在
持有甲骨文的朋友呢
多回回去
好这个是甲骨文
给大家简单的讲一下
下个星期等财报之后咱们再说
另外今天还有一个
大家可能比较关注的是特斯拉
特斯拉呢
昨天我们讲到它突破
然后今天直接一口气掉下来
我们看看先看看发生了什么
再看看这个价格后面会怎么走
特斯拉呢
是遭遇到了行政的狱击
根据华尔街日报的报道
美国国家公路交通安全管理局
已经是对这个CyberCab展开了审查
以确定它独特的设计
是否符合联邦安全法规
理由是什么呢
说这款双座车辆没有方向盘
脚套版或者传统的后视镜
让它好像不符合许多
旧的汽车法规中的一些既定标准
但是特斯拉声称
这个CyberCab是符合所有适用的联邦标准
美国国家公路交通安全管理局
现在是希望审查这个声明背后的技术数据和认证流程
包括特斯拉关于某些要求
可能不适用于专用自动驾驶车辆的认定
大家肯定会觉得奇怪
是吧
那特斯拉之前怎么不审批呢
怎么现在这个车都造出来了
这个后面要审批它呢
这个和美国的造车的相关法律相关
在美国呢
它是允许汽车制造商
你自己认证车辆
就是我自己造的一个车
合不合规
合不合联邦法规
而不是在生产之前
我有个图纸了
直接先给你先去批
这个不是这个流程
所以那么像美国国家公交通安全管理局
在车辆上路之后
他才提出一些质疑
那么这个是正常的
就是现在正在发生的状况
那大家会说
这个会不会很麻烦
会不会过不了
回头让他回去改
对吧
那就是个大事了
其实呢
这个并不是
特斯拉不是第一个被审查的
之前呢
其实早就有先例
亚马逊旗下的这个Zooks
他呢
也是因为之前不是推出了Zooks之后
他也是一款没有方向盘和脚踏板的
无人出租车嘛
对吧
长得跟那个宝宝巴是差不多
很可爱的样子
对吧
那么他当时呢
也是获得了认证
而且受到了监管机构的质疑
但是呢
Zooks是最终获得了豁免
而且允许他在特定限制条件下
进行商业运营
比如大家如果去Vegas
还有这个旧金山湾区
你都能看得到这个Zooks
所以啊
这件事呢
美国国家交通安全管理局
我认为啊
他最终还是会认定特斯拉没有问题
或者像这个Zooks一样是获得了豁免
毕竟你后此薄彼说不过去
是不是
你让Zooks过让这个Subcap不过
你这个就有点说不过去
好
那咱们就说回股价
从股价上看
昨天我们讲到特斯拉的突破
但是日线有顶背离的小毛病
今天正好趁着利空消息
下跌完成了修复
而且今天还是一个倒行反转
它是属于滞涨形态的一种
整个的修复下跌过程
确实是有点难看了
如果修复是分三天跌了六个点
大家可能没什么感觉
但是一天跌六个点
大家就觉得
我刚上车
这是又要套人了
对吧
感受不一样
其实差别就在这
是缓慢修复
还是一口气修复
结果反正就是
它现在修复了
挺好
那么这个对于中长线来讲
在突破之后
其实这个技术性的修复
是好事情
我个人看
现在大家对于特斯拉
如果你想做它的波段
只需要考虑一件事
昨天给大家更新了一些强弱位置和重要的点
在突破之后
第一个防守位置是331
第二个是防守是在315
其实想做波段的
你只需要考虑在回撤完了之后
他给了你一个更低的
可以去考虑盈亏比的价格的机会
你只需要考虑盈亏比你能不能合适你如果觉得能承受比方说350块351块跌到331块以破位20块钱的止损风险
去打一个到415块
打一个大概60块钱的一个盈利空间
你合不合适
你能不能接受
其实就考虑这个事情
或者你更宽一点
你从这里到315块
那差不多你按355算
有40块钱的止损风险
去打一个向上方的一个60块钱的指引空间
你有没有觉得合不合适
无非就差别就在这里
为什么特斯拉的做法一直都是这样
是因为我们老观众应该知道
咱们在讲特斯拉的时候
一直在讲基本面上肯定是不值这个价
因为它的前程固执
无论你从哪个方面去算
它都是不值这个价
但是它的技术面上
一直都是被广大的
包括机构以及散户
用来疯狂的做波段的
因为它的空间很大
振幅相当的大
动不动就是20% 30% 30% 30% 40%
这个区间足够大家吃了
所以它就变成了这么一个
波动性极高
波段属性极高的股票
对吧
特斯拉咱们也讲过
它也不叫特斯拉
它叫波斯拉
其实就这么来的
好
所以特斯拉的问题
跟大家一次性也讲完了
剩下的大家就自行考虑
你要冒什么样的风险
去承受
去寻求什么样的一个收益
好
然后再说一下AMD
AMD昨天刚刚讲过
今天是跟着费半一起启示了
大家密切关注
它是否能够完成突破
因为它的走势
今天是一个放量
走势和费半的走势
非常的类似
下降趋势线
这整个的结构也差不多
那么它在突破498
止跌之后
那么它预计的好日子
也可能就不远了
尽管上方还需要突破528才新高
但只要突破了下行趋势压制
进入了止跌之后
资金有可能会回流
特别是非半那边也一同突破
对吧
都突破了下降趋势压制
非半又成了市场关注的一个重点
这对于MD来讲
那不就是好事吗
很明显今天他和英伟达比强得多
英伟达今天是高开之后
然后几乎把盘中的涨幅都吃光了
但今天大家会说英伟达是不是见顶形态
今天是见顶形态
但是英伟达今天见顶形态收盘价所在的位置
是近期的新高
这种情况通常我们在见顶形态的
有效性的排序里边是往后排
那么这种情况的看待是中性看法
需要再观察几天
不能够作为直接马上就说他见顶了
或者要大幅下跌了
不能做这个判断
所以英伟达他今天这个走势也给大家跟一下
好
所以MD的情况
我们昨天讲了
今天也讲了
后面大家就自行关注了
我们看看他的后面走势如何
看看它能不能够再次回到之前的
那个神勇状态
毕竟呢这轮回车之后
我们从基本面上也谈过
它的情况已经回到了合理水平
相对比较合理的位置
和之前在500多块高估的位置相比
那这个地方合理的多了
好
然后还有什么可讲的呢
微软
哎呀
微软今天
这个没啥好讲的
微软今天加入了谷歌和亚马逊的行列
对吧
那今天的走势很明显是想帮这个亚马逊和谷歌
分担一些挨骂的火力啊
那大家也这个趁它下跌的时候
该骂的时候多骂两句哈
回头这个回撤完毕了
修复好了啊
过两天突破涨起来了
那又骂不着了啊
所以这两天大家随便骂哈
好
然后亚马逊和谷歌这个就没有什么可说的了
昨天讲过
对吧
连几天都在讲
苹果这边的情况呢
今天这两天走的
今天走的不好啊
但它这个价格本身就
还是比较无聊的
它也没什么可多讲的
因为这个价格老实讲
价格太高了
今年九月前瞻在288块
它这个应该是在
28年九月的前瞻估值的位置
好
其他的今天呢
就不打算多讲了
下个星期一是美股休市
所以这个星期它是长周末
那么咱们这个会员节目按照惯例
所以长周末会停更一期
这个星期大家也不必等待会员节目
大家也都好好休息
好吧
好
那这个就是咱们今天节目的全部内容
如果你觉得我的节目对你所帮助
还是希望大家能够多多帮忙
点赞
评论
转发
谢谢大家
最后祝大家长周末快乐
咱们下一次见面
就得是下个星期二的盘后
美东时间下个星期二的盘后
好
那咱们进行到这吧
咱们就下周二的盘后再聊
祝大家周末快乐